assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this brand new show
on iman channel talk to me
I'm your host Ali da WA this shows gonna
be a bit different
we're gonna have some controversial
topics that were going to discuss and
the audience are gonna have their say
I'm for a panel of guests I'm gonna
start on my left brother what's your
name Hamza I'm and why are you sitting
like that what's your job here today
okay so I'm going to be playing devil's
advocate I'm going to have controversial
opinions yes they're not my own opinions
but I'm an associate rest and adopts
opinions for example if there's if we're
talking about certain topic he's going
to come from another aspect so it's fair
and more exciting shala and also on his
left we caught brother use brother Yusuf
I was gonna say you know Yusuf blessing
each other and then on my right we have
brother Muhammad hijab I dunno key no
bad you seem a bit tight today
alright and we move on he's right who's
how you I'm Neela oh good okay good so
what's today's topic you know Musa yeah
it's interracial marriages so today's
topic is interracial marriages yeah and
lots of us may be in an interracial
marriage ourselves a lot of us maybe
during the marriage process got denied
you know like for example because you
know you're from this cast
you're not from my tribe you're this
color you're green blue yellow whatever
it may be and you have been rejected
yeah so today is your time and maybe
there's no brothers here or sisters have
gone through that there so the first
question that needs to be asked I think
the first question I need to ask is
where does this mentality come from like
cuz we are Muslims yeah in its now we
don't have race the process of selling
didn't tell us when you're gonna get
married look at what color the
individual is or what tribe they're from
so where do you think this problem stems
from what we've done is basically
essentially we've come from back home
our parents have come from calm our
parents all came here and they lived
here so back home you don't see people
getting married to different people from
different races back home obviously
everyone's gonna marry
from their country yeah so when the
parents come here and their children
when we go to school we have people in
our cluster are from all different
countries you know from all walks of
life or all faiths and we choose someone
that we want to marry from a different
country even if that person be a Muslim
yeah of course what ends up happening is
it something that strains to our
appearance a lot of the time you're
marrying someone outside so culturally
yeah I feel like it's not accepted in a
lot of countries the question that needs
to be our series where is this coming
from you know is there anyone in the
audience who know somebody or have
personally gone through this issue of
you know wanted to marry somebody from a
different caste or race but has been
rejected does anybody know anyone
specifically we'll just go for this
inshallah isaki this is a friend of mine
who actually went through this he did go
for a lot of trouble basically because
of different cultures and exactly I do
agree with the brother said that it's
the culture of the parents where they
come from a cultural background but also
at the same time I don't blame them but
for youngsters I think the main problem
is I think the root problem is it's a
lack of education about Islam and what
Islam says so our parents Marshall
Miller bless them they're very grounded
in the couches because this is how they
grew up you said they have a right are
you talking about the parents here yeah
okay so I would I would like to ask a
question because when you mean they have
a right is that based on Islamic culture
because like you said you know this is
what they took from their culture well
this one fella says it tells us in the
Quran are you gonna follow your
forefathers even though you know that
they were in the wrong so somebody might
come and ask the question and say yes
okay you're saying they have a right but
based on what Islam or what we're
talking about here when I do see parents
have the right it's not right based on
on Islam but from where they are coming
from so I think in the society nowadays
the main problem comes where you know
we're talking about the issue but if we
can be balanced in both so you see where
they're coming from and where we're
coming from
that's where the clear line shows that
we're coming from what's alarm says
while they're coming from from they're
coming from a culture background what's
required from us is that we need to show
some form of steady education towards
our parents because eventually we have
to break down these false ideas so this
requires you know soft dowel with the
parents because they are parents they
are above our heads islamically they are
above our heads and they want what's
best for us okay you mentioned a few
there obviously our parents are above
our heads yeah but what about our laws
laws because this is something really
important because this is this is where
we have to choose here okay this doesn't
mean we disobey our parents but there's
a fine line yeah yes our parents we obey
them but if they tell us to do something
which is against our laws Commandments
and laws which I personally from my
perspective I could come and say that's
outright racism you know is there anyone
in the audience that where do you think
parents are coming from like if I can go
to this sister even between Somalis they
don't want someone who's a different
yeah I think tribe yeah so it's much
deeper than being a London Eye it's much
it's something that has existed for a
long time so I think that's just okay
sometimes doesn't have to do with
culture it's about the parents they're
quite afraid that the children are here
in this country and that they when
they're in this interracial marriage
that they would disappear they would not
go back to their roots okay lose their
was the culture the language their
heritage their origin where they're
coming from they won't know about their
father but you know the grandparents and
the many many many parents are afraid
that this interracial marriage won't
last
okay and that could be a problem for the
parents I agree with certain points is
that you said they would lose their
culture but I understand where you're
coming from but the sister the question
that really needs to be asked here is is
your culture and I don't mean you I'm
just saying that a general in person is
our coach are gonna save us all of their
judgment
if not if not enough for example as a
pet as a parent who's worried you might
think you know what well I would want
somebody to speak the same languages my
child etc you know they understand that
you know but when when it comes to the
point of where they are coming in saying
you know what no like it's you can't its
they make it hard on something that's
halal does Haram so what would you say
to that cuz I understand the culture
aspect of it sister here I'm gonna go to
baroque but before I go to him from from
your point of view are you are you
trying to say that look they have a
right to that for example they have a
right to say you know what daughter son
I'd prefer you to marry somebody that's
Pakistani oh are you singing no like
that's it like is it a matter of right
that it's a choice or they should like a
person in your circle would you allow
your child if they wanted to marry
somebody from outside your costly would
you allow that no okay
just so the people understand what is
the main fundamental reason why would
any level I think I see the up being of
of my when I was younger that I need
stability in my life and I think that
being in intuition my sometimes makes
people don't have any kind of origin
nothing nothing to go in comment they
don't have that no yeah I mean like the
children when they're older they don't
know which country they will be from and
they're just I mean Islam is it is a
good thing it's a revision and you go
back to that but you have to also have
some kind of thing some kind of roots
some kind of stability so that you know
you know
those interracial marriages cause
unstable bility because this this is
where this maybe the sisters coming from
what's your take on this I'm in a
interracial marriage you want to cool it
yeah
my wife she's from Kashmir hamdulillah
and I'm a white British man now I
forsake my culture for the sake of Islam
my culture is a culture of drinking my
culture is a culture of going out and
partying my culture is a culture of not
being married this is what it's become
yeah in my culture I'm from Scotland
originally it's very heavy drinking and
and very heavy partying that's the
culture um problem I gave up my culture
now if we take what the sister said and
make it a staple in what we decide in
our lives that culture is very important
that my children understand my culture
and where I come from then this would
have a negative impact on the family for
sure
without a doubt yeah culture was
destroyed 1,400 years ago in Mecca what
did they say when the prophesy center
started to French they said he's come to
change what our forefathers brought he's
destroying our society what he's
preaching is splitting father from sons
daughter from from father destroying
family lives it's what they said
subhanAllah
and I say alhamdulillah that it did
because if we limit what we have in our
family to what our culture brings then
we're not going to be able to taste the
beauty of different other ways of living
as a Muslim now I'm not saying that you
can't be British a Muslim you can yeah
this Muslim who is British you're Muslim
first before you're British you're a
Muslim before you are Somali you are
Muslim before you are Pakistani etcetra
etcetra etcetra Hamza
I disagree with them brother frogs point
I don't think Islam came to sort of
completely smashed culture cultures and
a bad thing
what the Prophet came to smash was
idolatry but I think sometimes our
parents know best they know us better
than everyone anyone else and so if they
know that way so used to sort of being
raised up in a particular way you know
we're used to having our royalty not
curry and they know that if we were to
marry someone from another culture
you know that woman from another culture
wouldn't be able to provide for you in
the same way as your mother would he's
from the same cultures you especially
you know where I'm from the divorce
rates are really high where for example
Bengali sisters or African brothers are
marrying into marrying Bengali sisters
yeah and there's a mismatch there you
know the African brother goes to the
tease wife's house and again it's such a
culture clash there it's impossible to
sort of integrate curry is not going to
save me in the hereafter for example you
know that few differences yeah let's
just go to the cysteine Saleh hey sister
what's your take on the matter as we've
heard the parents that the the children
may not be able to adapt to the culture
well the issue is is a bit hypocritical
because oftentimes parents want to make
sure that everything is good on paper
they have a good degree there from our
tribe but then they don't look at things
like spirituality the carrots are our
children compatible and then this thing
could lead to a bad marriage as much as
if not more than people from different
races so I don't really agree with that
point very valid points like when
looking for a partner why do we always
concentrate about the degree the work
there's color its race why don't we talk
about his top wahoo Salah is their car
let's go to the sister we I think it's
not necessarily bad to have reservations
as opposed to being outright against it
but different cultures do practice Islam
in different ways so what we have is
some families and some difficulties will
not approve of her job will not approve
of the son growing the beard and you
know marrying into a family where you're
going to be sort of scrutinized for
practicing Islam in a certain way could
be an issue